if there is an author and illustrator of
children's books working today worthy of
dr. Seuss's mantle he is Mo Willems his
best-selling adventures for young
readers include don't let the pigeon
drive the bus along with his elephant
and piggy series now the New York
Historical Society has brought together
original art sketches and drawings from
his most popular books and I was
fortunate enough to meet him for a chat
do you get a little emotional seeing
them all hanging in one place I do every
picture displayed at the New York
Historical Society tells the story about
Mo Willems this is before we did stuff
digitally these are the actual cells but
some of them like how he created
elephant's friend piggy only he can
bring to life it was sort of an open
casting call I had a muskrat
I had a squirrel with a helmet I had all
different sort of sidekicks and nothing
really gelled and then piggy showed up
and she was so piggy and so sweet and so
pure that she got cashed she got the
role I love that if I didn't know these
were characters I would think you were
talking about real people completely
real his passion for characters started
as a child growing up in New Orleans the
girl of my dreams
Willem says he was inspired by Charlie
Brown created by Charles Schulz Charlie
Brown's head is a circle Snoopy is just
sort of a jelly bean so I just drew
Charlie Brown's and Snoopy's every
single day and that's what made me want
to be a cartoonist when I was five I
wrote trow Schulz a letter that said
dear mr. Schulz can I have your job when
you're dead and I just waited and was
there any response no no my father never
sent the letter everyone Williams moved
from New Orleans to New York to attend
NYU's prestigious Tisch School of the
Arts like 24 he was performing sketch
comedy while working at Sesame Street
his work over nine seasons earned him
six Emmy Awards when you left Sesame
Street did you think there's something
about writing for kids that I love
no it wasn't I actually discovered it
there I think in the beginning when I
got hired I thought oh I'm doing sketch
comedy that's great kids MS always what
you wanna hear from someone is great but
what I discovered it really shocked me
was it's harder to write for kids
because you don't have cultural
modifiers you can't reference bands or
cultural experiences or whatnot you're
stuck with core fundamental
philosophical thoughts anger jealousy
that kind of thing
anger became the selling point for
Williams first best-selling character
simply drawn and simply named the pigeon
I want to make sure that every lead
character that I create can be
reasonably copied by a five-year-old and
it will look like that character his
next breakthrough character was kunafa
bunny featuring a toddler named Trixie
the character was named and based on his
real daughter Trixie she was 2 when the
first book was published and 4 when she
voiced the character now huh bunny is
all true now she's 15 you know being the
real Trixie is kind of contained in one
part of my life and then I go and I
visit places like this and I'm suddenly
at this museum where all my dad's stuff
is being held I'm like right this is a
thing a thing parents and kids are
willing to wait in long lines for
especially to hear Willems voice the
characters from the final elephant and
piggy book bank
it's called the thank you book and this
cover is the 25th in the series over the
years Peggy's ears have gotten bigger
because she's aged and gels ears have
gotten bigger and lower I want to go
back to projects that really freaked me
out
that I think can I do this and then I
can use that that energy of being
terrified to push myself to do something
that hopefully will be meaningful
while the tour shows you all the effort
behind Willems seeming effortlessness he
says every book should look like anyone
could have done it I think that the
mistake that people make is they think
that ideas are things that you get like
shoes and I not ideas or things that you
grow and every day you go back and you
take your sketchbook and you're planting
a little seed and some of them just
don't grow at all and every now and then
one of those seeds slowly slowly grows
up and becomes beautiful tree that bears
fruit that you can cut down and burn for
profit I mean you can see there he is so
incredibly thoughtful one of the things
I asked him is that the words that come
first
is it the drawings and he says he's such
a minimalist one could not exist without
the other they should lean together I
have to say his attention to detail
reminded me a lot of you haha well I
loved his philosophy that ideas are
things that you grow but they're just
that you don't just they're not just
there you have to work with them and
some of them don't grow I got to start
planting it's time we all gotta start
planting